bienvenue sur 9,7 cas télé dans votre
émission vivre ensemble aujourd'hui nous
recevons pierre raynaud et christine
huet de la ccit base parmi nous
également nicolas un petit mas usagers
réguliers la ccib à ce qui nous fera
partager son expérience
bonjour à tous monsieur raynaud vous
êtes responsable de la ccit base
expliquez nous en quoi ça consiste
bonjour merci à 9,7 catelli de nous
recevoir
la ccit base la ccit base existe depuis
maintenant plus de dix ans elle a été
créée en 2005 et la ccit base est un
espace public numérique accessible et
adapté aux personnes aveugles et
malvoyantes qui se situe dans le sud de
l'île à saint pierre sur le boulevard
banques
c'est un service du conseil
départemental donc depuis 2005 quand je
disais quelle est la mission principale
d'une c6 base alors la mission précise
principal de la ccit base c'est
d'accueillir ce public là les aveugles
et les personnes aveugles et personnes
malvoyantes et de leur permettre
d'accéder aux nouvelles technologies de
l'information et la communication qu'on
appelle aussi ntic qui sont plus si
nouvelle que ça quand même c'est à dire
qu'on met à la disposition de ce public
là des postes
connecté à internet que ce soit
ordinateurs tablettes munies de
dispositifs adaptés à notre déficience
visuelle pour les personnes aveugles des
synthèses vocales donc la machine qui
parle d plage braille c'est à dire des
écrans braille qui reproduisent sous les
doigts ce qui est affiché à l'écran et
éventuellement des claviers adapté pour
les personnes malvoyantes donc qui voit
plus que moi et moins que vous il y a
des grands écrans des dispositifs de
grossissement à l'écran ou sur les
tablettes de modification des couleurs
des contrastes mais ça je pense que
christine on parlera encore mieux que
moi de ces outils là tout à l'heure et
évidemment elle met à la disposition des
locaux je les dis tout à leur résidence
vitaly budvar banques et une équipe de
quatre professionnels
je suis j'en suis le responsable mais je
suis accompagné au quotidien par
christine huet yacoub laon bat et à l'ex
mirabeau qui constitue donc l'équipe de
la ccit base mais muette
vous travaillez avec claire hainaut quel
est votre rôle auprès des utilisateurs
de la ccit vase
alors j'ai le plaisir de travailler que
monsieur rénaux depuis deux ans à la
ccit pas où nous accompagnons jeu nous
sommes chargés d'accompagner les
personnes déficientes visuelles aveugles
et malvoyantes à la l'utilisation ou
voir à l'apprentissage de l'informatique
adapté ou de l'utilisation du matériel
de lecture matériel adapté je dirais
matériel informatique des ordinateurs
comme monsieur tout le monde mais muni
de logiciels adaptés logiciels de
vocalisation et d'agrandissement d'écran
pour ma part je suis moi-même
malvoyantes donc je m'occupe plus
aisément des personnes dans ma situation
avec un matériel adapté
c'est à dire avec un clavier en gros
caractères un logiciels de vocalisation
mais surtout deux homes d'écran d'accord
mais si hamdi moi vous vous êtes usager
à taissy vase
qu'est ce que vous préférez utiliser
comme outil est là bas ben là bas comme
ça va parce que mine bien du coup un peu
double nouveauté plage braille
smartphones de tout ce qui touche à la
téléphonie gains l'iphone tout cela mais
aussi le bloc note aussi parce que des
fois avant ça il faut dire avant il
fallait à l'heure soit en leur métropole
tout ça te laver la chance de les voir
dit puisque nana comme matériel
messieurs tout leur catalogue et au
choix des produits blue vient pas testé
tandis que la longue et tester un petit
peu tout les produits que la sécurité de
l'onu utilise le plus haut niveau bloc
notes tout ça
donc voila un petit peu
même que tout échange un petit peu et
télécharger des applications
ce au niveau de l'iphone tout cela
riesch all i want plus salée gaillard
entre tout ça est beaucoup plus
accessible maintenant et depuis combien
de temps vous allez à ses six bases bain
de pieds loulou etien parce qu'il a tous
je travaille en somme avec l'association
valentin haüy aussi ont un indien sur
toutes les voies d'ici peu toutes les
problèmes de faune rencontre nouveau
transpole bon mot mythe déplacer en car
jeunes depuis sony parce que c'est ni la
fois encore elle avait coûté médiathèque
que c'est marie mai après les nageurs
minimum et la banane un peu plus de soin
d'ailleurs un mystère que le conseil
départemental et de deux collectivités
donc vous êtes autonome vous prenez
votre carte jaune et vous allez assez ci
basée à saint pierre voilà mais ça va
oui c'est magique à ses pieds après
celle qui m'appelle ben ali cherche à
malaga d'accord mais sur hainaut vous
avez d'autres missions également vous
vouliez nous parler de des autres
missions nassib alors les autres
missions et peut-être répondre à nicolas
un petit mot sur les historiques en deux
mots de la ccit base dans ces six bases
a été créé dans le sud
à l'époque en 2005 parce que justement
dans le nord il y avait une section
informatique dans une médiathèque comme
l'a dit nicolas et c'est vrai que depuis
je dirais qu'ils allaient le côté
informatique né il n'ya plus le côté
informatique dans cette section
déficients visuels de la médiathèque
donc le dispositif c6 base est unique à
la réunion se situe dans le sud
unique à la réunion est très rare en
métropole puisque c'est extrêmement rare
qu'un conseil départemental et en son
sein un service du type de la ccit base
donc c'est vrai qu'on est encore une
fois la réunion nous sommes précurseurs
dans ce dans ce domaine là alors pour
répondre à votre question les autres
missions de la ccit base c'est une
mission très large auprès des déficients
visuels qui est un public très isolés
donc on est on est on va dire un lieu de
rencontre et de convivialité au niveau
de la déficience jeune mais ça je pense
que christine on parlera encore mieux
que moi
nous avons une mission d'information de
sensibilisation à la déficience visuelle
auprès des personnes qui le souhaitent
c'est un appel que je peux lancer auprès
des écoles des collèges des lycées des
maisons de retraite des médiathèques
on intervient pour sensibiliser le
public les professionnels à la
déficience visuelle parce que c'est
important pour que nous déficients
visuels on sommes mieux intégrés dans la
société réunionnaise autres autre
mission donc on est un espace public
numérique donc les gens peuvent venir
à notre rencontre on est un service
public gratuit ouvert à tous
ça c'est important de le dire et de le
redire
on accueille bien volontiers les
personnes aveugles et malvoyantes mais
on accueille aussi bien volontiers le
public que je qualifierais de curieux et
les professionnels autre mission delà de
la ccit base on essaye et on n'y arrive
pas trop mal à animer le réseau des
partenaires en déficience visuelle
parce que la c6 base est intégré dans ce
réseau et grâce aux partenaires on peut
vraiment évolué dans le bon sens
toujours mieux servir ce public-là et la
dernière mission qui m'incombe peut-être
plus particulièrement c'est d'être au
sein du département de la réunion
expert en accessibilité numérique de la
même manière qu'il existe de
l'accessibilité aux transports à la voir
et à la voirie aux établissements
recevant du public vous le savez
peut-être pas mais il existe des normes
qui régissent des normes des bonnes
pratiques qui régissent l'accès au
numérique pour les personnes en
situation de handicap en général et les
seniors je résumerai d'une phrase
l'accessibilité numérique pour les
personnes en situation de handicap et
les seniors c'est un confort pour tous
en disant vous avez dû connaître une
énorme évolution dans les outils qui
sont à votre disposition j'imagine alors
de toute façon pour nous personnes
aveugles et malvoyantes les nouvelles
technologies le numérique la révolution
du numérique est pour nous une véritable
révolution un bond en avant sans
précédent en termes d'autonomie et
depuis dix ans la principale évolution
nicolas la cité tout à l'heure c'est un
c'est en fait la possibilité d'avoir un
smartphone tactile vocaliser c'est à
dire de pouvoir comme tout un chacun
utiliser un smartphone qui qui nous rend
avec lequel évidemment on peut
téléphoner mais téléphoner
et une des options de ces outils
merveilleux qui pour nous nous sont
complètement accessible cette révolution
s'est passé en 2009
et c'est pour nous déficients visuels la
principale révolution qui a eu dans ces
dix dernières années veut dire votre vie
a changé ces outils c'est pas c'est
vraiment pas trop fort comme comment ça
a changé complètement notre vie moi je
dirais je dis toujours de façon un peu
lyrique c'est le premier objet que je
prends matin dans les mains puisque ça
me sert de réveil matin et le dernier
qui est objet que le jeu l'âge puisque
j'aurai et je règle mon réveil matin
pour le lendemain
mais entre temps j'ai accès à mes mails
à internet à la musique à la radio
journaux et aux réseaux sociaux enfin
tout ce que vous faites vous je dirais
que ce qui nous est ce qui nous est
interdit pour nous non voyons mais à la
limite pour les malvoyants c'est déjà
autre chose c'est ce qui touche vraiment
à l'image c'est à dire que je ne peux
pas faire du photoshop par exemple mais
tout le reste quasiment nous est permis
avec la restriction de cette fameuse
accessibilité numérique qui nous frustre
trop trop souvent et des fois il arrive
à nous mêmes que nous les voyons dans
les applications des phases et y connait
pas trop haut du bâtiment et ça les
gagnants c'est ça me rappelle de voir
autrement aussi et vous m bah pour moi
ces pollutions d'ailleurs pas si
aujourd'hui je suis à la ccit base passé
grâce à cette évolution des du numérique
et ben ça et essayer c'est grâce à ça
aussi que je peux cheval je pense avoir
les compétences pour transmettre à ceux
qui n'ont pas accès au numérique
sens une machine à écrire des poinçons
l'écriture en braille font une toute
autre forme d'expression pour ces
candidats tous participent aujourd'hui à
la 21e édition du concours de dictée
brest et le fond ou avec une tablette
alors pas un ipad une tablette c'est un
une plaque en fer avec des trous dedans
et le candidat avec un poinçon point
embauche chaque point les uns après les
autres ça c'est on va dire c'est
l'appareil le plus rustique le plus
ancien pour écrire le braille qui existe
certains écrits donc avec une tablette
un poinçon et d'autres écrivent avec une
machine braille alors vous savez c'est
un peu comme frigidaire au réfrigérateur
c'est une machine whitechapel perkins
parce que c'est la plus répandue
même si ces noms propres et là c'est une
machine où vous retrouvez en fait un
clavier avec avec un point partouche qui
permet de composer le nombre de points à
chaque achat caractère un concours
national dont l'objectif est de
valoriser l'écriture braille auprès des
personnes aveugles ou malvoyantes
ils sont une dizaine à concourir à la
réunion et une centaine au plan national
près de 1,3 milliard d'euros
je pense que c'est un challenge de plus
pour les déficients
visuel et surtout bassett pour ceux qui
ont quitté le circuit scolaire c'est le
cas aujourd'hui de montrer justement qui
n'ont pas oublié
eux ce qu'ils ont à prier à l'école
c'est difficile parce qu'il y avait
beaucoup de de mendiants 2 2 il y avait
beaucoup de typographie dedans donc
dégradé et alité que ça donc vous allez
faire attention c'est pas difficile pour
l'orthographe je suis sûr que c'est bon
après pour le reste je sais pas pendant
deux heures les candidats rédigeront en
braille cette dictée d'une quinzaine de
lignes pour les sudistes la rédaction se
déroule à la ccit base un dispositif du
département qui mettent en place des
outils d'accès aux technologies de
l'information et de la communication
dédiée aux personnes aveugles et
malvoyantes
donc c'est un espace multimédia ou mis à
la disposition du public sans aucune
condition on va dire sauf des conditions
peut-être rendez vous pour qu'on puisse
se libérer au mieux pour les gens qui le
rendent visite
on met à disposition des les nouvelles
technologies adaptées et accessible aux
personnes aveugles et malvoyantes
c'est à dire des postes informatiques
connectés à internet que ce soit des
ordinateurs des tablettes
assurer nos quel rôle jouent les
partenaires dans le fonctionnement
nécessite base extrêmement important
parce qu'on travaille très réguliers
avec eux alors le partenaire privilégié
on peut le dire aujourd'hui qui est qui
est conventionné d'ailleurs avec le
département depuis 2012
nicolas un petit monde parlait tout à
l'heure c'est le comité valentin oui de
la réunion de l'océan indien qui est une
quête une association au service des
personnes aveugles et malvoyantes qui a
une antenne régionale à la réunion un
exemple très simple parmi d'autres
nicolet team a cité les smartphones à la
ccit base nous avons du matériel
appartenant donc au conseil
départemental donc ordinateurs tablettes
et périphériques adaptés mais pour des
raisons de complexité on va dire on n'a
pas la possibilité d'avoir des
smartphones pour pour les montrer au
public et aujourd'hui c'est quand même
ce que demande le plus le public les
smartphones et les tablettes dont nous
travaillons avec cette association et en
particulier à monsieur qui s'appelle
avec 5 cuvelliez qui est le spécialiste
téléphonie mobile adapté et accessible
au sein de cette association et qui tous
les jeudis assure une permanence et
reçoit un public assez nombreux je dois
dire qui vient de demander conseil sur
les smartphones accessibles et adaptés
pour les personnes aveugles et
malvoyantes aujourd'hui et c'est grâce à
cette association et en partenariat avec
cet intervenant que l'on peut proposer
ce service extrêmement demandée par le
public très bien mais muette au delà de
l'aspect technique pratique vous
endossez de nombreuses casquettes tout
au long la journée j'imagine
racontez nous au delà de notre rôle
d'initiateur à l'informatique
nous avons également le plaisir je
dirais pas de date d'accueillir le
public et de les aider ben finalement
dans l'aide que nous apportons pas nous
jouons un peu le rôle de psychologue
quelques jours ont quelquefois on se dit
bon on est psychologue on est assistante
sociale parce qu'on les accompagne dans
leurs démarches dans
on est à leur écoute quoi oui vous leur
offrez un lieu convivial déjà à
l'accueil essayer de les mettre à l'aise
d'avoir un petit entretien avec eux ben
pour justement pouvoir personnaliser
l'accompagnement au matériel numérique
mais il ya autre d'autres personnes qui
vont venir à la ccit base part à la
recherche de numérique mais de deux
rencontres de personnes d'autres
personnes pour mieux se sentir et sa
fille voir également vous par mois la
sortie afin de fuir de l'iss et surtout
sortir de l isolement est également axée
n'a pas accepté mais mieux appréhender
leur handicap
d'accord en fait on partage son
expérience également avec d'autres
personnes porteuses d'un handicap vous
voyez pas en tant que déjà en tant que
mal voyantes comme je le disais tout à
l'heure je pense que c'est plus facile
pour moi de les accompagner dans parler
avec eux et de leur donner des exemples
qui sont plus concrets que si c'était
une personne qui voit qui leur explique
ray je pense que ça n'est plus crédible
et plus encourageant très bien monsieur
un petit mois vous vous aimez justement
cet aspect convivial de la ccib ah ben
oui parce que là les rencontres où ils
sont bons peu
aux affaires nous n'a nulle part où on a
un petit problème de sitel mateille et
puis il permet d'échanger un petit peu
il ya non plus ici c'est un gros
problème mais moins bien que justement
ce qui fait un jouet se bat comme si le
transport parce que le déplacement est
pas facile pour nous déjà en exil en
général à travers les âges c'est parce
qu'on ne gagne
oui il est vrai que c'est celle
événement convivial y travaillent y
échangent et puis nous c'est continuer à
essayer ce matin si peu pour que le
transport avant c'est une belle robe les
problèmes que des fois nous me rend
compte et surtout le côté gaillard ainsi
que nous partager ses soeurs serena un
mot pour conclure un humain mossad être
difficile à gérer ce dispositif qui qui
dure depuis dix ans et j'espère vraiment
qu'il va durer encore longtemps parce
qu'il rend de grands services à ce
public
la ccib à sedan m'accueille on travaille
aussi à distance beaucoup par téléphone
on peut aussi se déplacer à l'admr je
les dis très important voilà pour
résumer un peu ce que ce qu'a très bien
dit christine notre rôle est aussi
d'accueillir d'écouter d'informer et
d'orienter ce public là vers d'autres
partenaires
elle de parler évidemment mais on n'est
pas psychologue n'est pas assistante
sociale mais on est on est on est un
service public donc qui est ce ce rôle
là nous tient énormément à coeur
donc comme on connaît bien le réseau des
acteurs en déficience du jade ça nous
permet en fonction de ce que les gens
vont nous dire que les orienter ou vers
des partenaires associatifs
institutionnels ou aussi vers d'autres
services évidemment du conseil
départemental puisqu'on et on fait
partie du conseil départemental et et et
nous en sommes fiers et nous notre rôle
est aussi de dd ce public là dedans à
comprendre un peu comment comment le
conseil départemental fonctionne et qui
peut les aider dans notre dans notre
grande maison
le partenariat pour nous est très très
important la communication également
puisque c'est aussi le seul la seule
façon que nous avons pour rejoindre un
public est extrêmement isolées qui ne
connaît pas qui est inconnu même des
tissus associatif et à chaque fois que
nous communiquons sur la c6 base on a
des personnes qui ne nous qu'on ne sont
pas que les partenaires ne connaissent
pas et qui viennent nous rencontrer et
il ya des moments très très fort en
termes humains puisque peut-être le mot
de la conclusion avant de donner les
coordonnées de la ccit base oralement
c'est les nouvelles technologies pour
moi qui suis spécialiste depuis de
nombreuses années ne m'intéresse que si
ça sert l'humain c'est pas les nouvelles
technologies qui sait on n'est pas au
service des nouvelles technologies mais
c'est les nouvelles technologies qui
sont au service des humains et ans et en
particulier de nous une main à besoins
particuliers convaincre comment on va
dire ou personnes en situation de
handicap
c'est ça qui ont fait vraiment l'intérêt
de ses nouvelles
la ccid du conseil départemental nous
serons heureux de vous recevoir
n'hésitez pas à nous appeler pour
prendre rendez vous ça nous permettra de
nous rendre au maximum disponible pour
vous recevoir dans les meilleures
conditions pour nous appeler composez le
0 2 162 57 98 27
je répète 0,260 2 57 98 27
vous pouvez également nous joindre par
mail ces six bases @ cg974 point fr
geipel cec ib as eu cec ib as e
@ cg974 point fr l'adresse de la ccit
base on est à saint pierre sur le
boulevard banques dans la résidence
guéthary nous sommes ouverts donc du
lundi au vendredi de 9h à 16h le
vendredi on s'arrête à 15 heures mais on
peut donc vous recevoir dans ses dents
cet horaire il nous arrive également de
faire de temps en temps des
manifestations le samedi ça arrive
que dire de plus c'est ouvert à tous on
est un service public gratuit ouvert à
tous
on vous demande quand même de nous
prévenir pour qu'on puisse se rendre
disponible pour vous recevoir dans les
meilleures conditions
merci et à très bientôt
donc notre émission se termine
je remercie nos invités de la ccib à son
monsieur qui m'a également mais si
j'attends encore merci il faut fuir pas
propre aux émissions comme ça ils
voyaient plus d'autres affirment qu'un
pareil que le jeu mais surtout il va
avec lequel l'esprit et surtout il met
la main pour que nous tout baignoire
plus loin on a bien compris
rendez vous dans une prochaine émission
de vivre ensemble très bientôt sur nos 7
4 télé bien si